éthique nous avons d'ailleurs rester en
italie pour parler de notre star du
football du football européen maintenant
et mondial michel platini est bien il a
resigné avec la juive il restera donc à
turin on croit savoir que bernard tapie
le nouveau patron de l'olympique de
marseille lui ai proposé pas moins de
cinq milliards de centimes pour venir
jouer à marseille de turin victor maman
qu'il pouvait sérieusement penser que
michel platini allait abandonner la ch26
même si on lui offrait 10 fois plus
d'argent ailleurs qu'à turin
il ya une espèce de contrat moral entre
platine et la juventus
platini à la juventus cela donne un
titre de champion d'italie une coupe
d'italie une coupe européenne des
champions une coupe des coupes une coupe
intercontinentale et même un titre
officieux de champion du monde des clubs
portant son fameux maillot numéro 10
michel platini a été le meilleur buteur
du championnat d'italie pendant trois
années consécutives avec 18 20 et encore
18 buts et il risque d'y avoir récidive
cette année michel platini se déclare
souvent excédés choqué par l'excès de
passion qui entoure le football en
italie ce n'est plus du sport c'est une
espèce d'incantation on attend de vous
le miracle tous les dimanches on y
perdrait même le plaisir de jouer au
ballon
la vénération qui entourent michel
platini en italie n'a plus de limites
et s'il est vrai que les tifosi sont
envahissants et insupportable il est
vrai aussi que seuls l'italie peut
donner à platini l'impression d'être
réellement le meilleur joueur du monde
est-ce qu'on parlait à ce point de
michel platini et dans le monde entier
avant qu'ils ne jouent à la juventus
devant des voix